[Applause]
my name is daniel guyar
just turned 30. growing up i've always
had a fight in my belly
i've always been pretty relentless with
whatever it is i'm trying to do
but unfortunately my body kind of has
not been treated
very well the past few years
dino all right
what do you want out of this i want to
be beast in everything you know body
mind and soul
i can do that for you buddy are you
ready to get beasted let's get basted so
daniel i've got my team beastie here
these two are my right and left hand men
we're going to take some measurements
we're going to do
height weight body fat those sort of
things
daniel get your top one mate let's get
ready to go
just get it come on
[Music]
you just bench press your own body
weight there
very impressive to be honest helps with
you watching
you're a strong guy but we want to be
stronger we want to be
be strong
that's one loop come on get it head up
right hand go and tense your hand in six
weeks time
this will be phenomenal
power now come on get it faster faster
yes done oh
that's quite fast we're going to write
you a program to take away you're going
to do you a diet
but first i want to take a picture of
you so we can get you back in six weeks
and we can see the difference
right frontal shot turn to your right 90
degrees
so we'll say big fat massive good luck
you will smash it see you in six weeks
well guys i'm super impressed with
daniel today i thought it was phenomenal
did well reminds me a lot of myself
actually he really does he's got that
determination to sort of get things done
but he's let his body slip right i'm
gonna order some pizzas
so yesterday i got beasted by eddie hall
which is just as cool as it sounds
a few days in i'm sure i'm very sure
i may have gone a little bit too hard
the first few days
i've actually invested in
microwave hopefully that'll minimize the
amount of times i have to eat
cold rice because it's a pain in the ass
hey dan i've been following your
progress and it looks like you've been
smashing it
we're about halfway through now and i
know things might be getting hard but
please don't give up
i'm sending chris and luke to check up
on you and give you some support
big love the beast hi chris hi everybody
good to see you oh yeah i'm going all
right
yeah it's getting there feeling really
good other than the diet
just the white rice everything else is
quite fine i think genuinely my mental
health is better i feel like i'm getting
stronger
as a as a body but i don't think it's
really
showing yet i think he's already
overcome his biggest challenge and
that's um
staying away from the pub and um keeping
away from us for six weeks
champagne that was my 30th birthday
present which i can't drink yet
here we are like the nerve center
organic butter nice yeah you told me to
just next to my dosing pump
yeah what is that us to inject chemical
into water systems yeah that looks real
healthy right next you peed
what could possibly go wrong
feeling good feeling happy working
harder
working clearer and i think there's so
many benefits that have come from
losing this weight funnily enough i
actually found two videos yesterday
one of which i'm 12. it kind of made me
reflect a bit on there i wasn't always
quite as self-assured i'm confident as i
am now
remember how i felt i didn't feel sort
of good enough confident enough to be
me i think a lot of my drive comes from
being a little bit intimidated
and scared you know i'm petrified of not
taking up
every opportunity that comes
hey dan how are you doing buddy hi eddie
yeah not too bad
your nickname is the pair who calls you
the pair
well apparently they all do i didn't i
didn't uh i didn't realize there were
things to do with my my upper body shape
that's pretty funny you look like you've
got a bit more definition on your
shoulders and chatting
and arms right i'm getting beasts good
man that's what that that's it they're
getting beastie
just spoke to dan seems very motivated
you know
but very confident almost over
confidence which is means you know going
forward now he might think he can slack
a little bit
we'll see but um i think dan's probably
the most promising one so far
i'm definitely keeping this up but this
isn't just going to be a
you know a six week project and then
they'll go back to my old ways you know
it's amazing to do with such an idol
eddie is a
is up there for me with my most
influential people you know
i think i'll be gutted if uh if he's not
tough with my progress
um i've really tried i want to be proud
of everything i've
done hi
so guys how how's it going diet
has been a challenge it's quite
anti-social we've not eaten together for
six weeks so here you guys got a
nickname for him we call him the pad i
think our coach made that up but he's a
little bit round in the bottom
i think probably the reason why he came
to this yeah there's probably a big
reason why he's done this actually
[Music]
me about it yeah it would be world cup
season quite a difficult
month to be uh to be off the beers what
does he know christopher
uh well on the skeleton there he's 92 so
we've got six kilos
six kilos yeah but the big news was his
lean mass is exactly
the same so it's pretty much all oh she
lost six kilos of fat
and what does that bring you down to
just around the twenty four percent mark
twenty four percent body fat
down to one and a half channels one and
a half chins now
we're gonna head outside to be the
farmers yeah it's one of your weaker
points wasn't it
oh yeah
i didn't want to say yeah so
this was your nemesis last time so when
you're ready mate
take your grip and
[Music]
get that speed down
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
you've nearly trebled your distance
that's absolutely
hectic there's one more thing to do i
know it's cold
if you don't mind taking your top off
and let's get the after picture give us
your best pose buddy
i'll just turn to your right for me
i've got a knob in there you have got an
ab in there it's just deep in there
are you ready for this amazing look at
the difference
it's really good should be very proud
what'd you guys think it's incredible
yeah i think out of all the guys the
sixth killer that came off
was all here it was like so visual
didn't come off his legs with his arms
it was all chest and abs phenomenal
result
from our part really this was hard
there's a few times i felt like
you know i've got too much on i can't do
this i can't do that something feels a
bit different about this time i think
i've overcome quite a few
mental hurdles and i've really backed up
my ball and absolutely got beasted
it's official you've been beasted thanks
for coming on the show buddy
you